The second Purge movie takes place 1 year
after the original and unemployment has risen
from 1% in the previous movie to 5%.
This may be a reflection of the economy in
the world of The Purge worsening, despite
the claims by the political group, The New
Founding Fathers of America, that The Purge
benefits the economy.
As we now know first hand, it turns out massive
amounts of death actually isn’t so great
for the economy as a whole, save for a select
few of the world’s wealthiest companies.
In our world, Walmart and Amazon are the rare
examples of thriving businesses, but in the
world of the Purge it’s all about weapon
manufacturers.
This all plays into the commentary that Anarchy
makes about gun violence in the US.
To learn the true meaning behind everything
that happens in Anarchy, including how Universal
took a SHOT at a rival film studio, stick
around to the end of this video.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
The first pur… the original Purge introduced
the New Founding Fathers, so this time around
we learn a little bit more about them and
we meet their opposition, a revolutionary
group headed up by Carmelo Johns.
Johns surmises that the Purge is a tool to
funnel money upward to the upper class: the
politicians and their rich donors.
It is the poor who are most likely to die
on Purge night, as they are unable to protect
themselves.
This makes it appear as if the NFFA is doing
a great job by cleaning up the streets and
reducing the taxes that go towards welfare
to take care of those people.
Those rich political donors that I mentioned
likely consist of two groups, those who sell
security, as we saw in the previous movie,
and those who sell weapons, which we start
to see in this movie.
Everyone wants to get in on the so-called
“holiday” sales trend.
Even the street vendors try to sell Eva weapons
as she walks home, telling her she needs them
as “protection” as casually as tourist
shops might tell vacationers that they need
an item to commemorate their trip, and these
are the same stalls that
you might find in LA selling t-shirts and postcards.
The use of The Purge as a money making tool
in 2023 is really only a slight exaggeration
of what goes on in real life, where organizations
like the NRA donate tens of millions of dollars
per year to fund election campaigns for politicians
who will do what they say, so when these weapons
are used for the inevitable act of terror,
the gun companies can rest assured that their
politicians won’t do anything to hurt their
weapon sales.
The satirization of American gun culture is
a thread that runs through the entire movie,
and seemingly the rest of the series, but
there are also other themes, and connections
you might not have noticed.
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
During the opening title, we see the seal
of The New Founding Fathers of America.
It’s very reminiscent of the Great Seal
of the United States, the differences being
that in the NFFA seal, the eagle is holding
an assault rifle and machete instead of arrows
and an olive branch.
The wings are much more rigid, like jet wings
and the glory of stars, which originally represented
the 13 American colonies coming together,
is thoughtfully replaced with two knifes coming
together -- a symbol of unification replaced
with a symbol of conflict.
The first character we meet is Eva, a waitress
taking care of a customer named Mr. Sabian.
“How is everything Mr. Sabian?”
"Great as always."
Sabian is a name that director James Demonaco
often includes in his movies as a director’s
trademark, but it has special meaning in The
Purge franchise, where it is often tied to
a character with some kind of link to the
NFFA.
In The Purge, Mr. Sabian was one of the neighbors
who went hunting during The Purge and in the
prequel, The First Purge, Arlo Sabian is the
NFFA Chief of Staff.
This time, Mr. Sabian is played by an actor
named Vick Sabian.
There’s another potential reference on the
TV.
The news scroller at one point reads: “A
drive along Oregon’s coast reveals soaring
sand dunes,” which may be a nod to the production
company, Platinum Dunes.
The news anchor also says that more people
will partake in this Purge than ever before.
I mentioned in the last episode that this
is the case in seemingly every Purge that
we’ve seen, and in Anarchy we find out why.
Roll it.
“Tonight we take lives.
We make things manageable for us.
Unfortunately, the citizens aren’t killing
enough.
So we supplement it all.
To keep things balanced.”
As commencement draws closer a married couple,
Shane and Liz rush to get to shelter and see
people putting out blue baptisias, which the
previous movie explains to be a sign of support
for the Purge.
We don’t see them as much as you would expect in this movie, which may be because of a shortage
caused by a drought, as explained in an article
on the NFFA website.
You can also spot men putting up plywood,
and this shot is a powerful visual representation
of what Carmelo Johns preaches about the poor
being the ones who suffer most during The
Purge, while the NFFA can afford to sit back
behind their high tech security systems.
While Eva is walking home, you can get a slight
glimpse of a poster advertising the suspension
of emergency services during The Purge, which
is actually just a movie poster from the ad
campaign of the original movie.
In that film, we encountered one group of
Purgers that wore creepy, nondescript masks.
Shane and Liz encounter a new group who travel
around on motorbikes, skateboards and a large
van.
Some of them have religious iconography on
their masks or faces.
The last movie did have a little bit of evidence
of The Purge starting to become a religion,
with the crazy neighbors holding hands and
reciting something like a prayer, the emergency
broadcast ending with this:
“...blessed be our New Founding Fathers
and America, a nation reborn”
...and maybe even the choice of flowers, the
blue baptisias, being a reference to baptism,
the symbolic form of purification in some
religions.
It goes along nicely with a phrase commonly
chanted by purgers:
"Purge and Purify!
Say it with me."
"Purge and Purify!"
Anarchy takes the religious parallels the
next level.
I think the idea is that by making the violence
into a religious experience, the NFFA hopes
people will look past their morals, and blindly
accept it as an OK thing to do.
Many people follow religion to help guide
their morality, but I’m sure you can also
think of examples of those who use their religion
as an excuse to justify horrible behaviour.
Like those nutcases who try to ban horror
movies.
Those people have strayed SO FAR from the
light.
"Purge and Purify!"
We see The Purge become more and more intertwined
with religion throughout the first three Purge
movies.
Carmelo calls this out in one of his rants.
“We no longer worship at the altar of Christ,
Mohammed, Yahweh.
We worship at the altar of Smith and Wesson.”
Smith and Wesson is a firearm manufacturer.
Next is the sniper woman acting as a herald
from a rooftop.
Her speech is rife with religious entitlement.
She says: “I'm doing God's work.
He uses an earthquake, a virus.
The masses nourish and flourish.
I am that virus tonight.
I am a one-woman f***ing plague and you're
all in my path!
I am the Holy Trinity.
I am the Father F***er, Son of a B****, and
Holy S***!
And my MP-9 silver-tipped Auto Magnum.
The right arm of the free world and the left
hand of God!
In flaming fire, I take the heads of them
that know not God.”
And the host of the Purge Gala at the end
of the movie describes one the weapons that
she considers her favorite.
“It is so precise it’s as if God had crafted
it himself.”
That brings me to the Purge countdown billboard.
When hacked by Carmelo’s group, it glitches
out and momentarily reveals a hidden message.
Probably the most iconic new villain in this
second Purge movie is this guy, who for obvious
reasons, I’ll just call “Godhead.”
It seems that he’s labeling himself as God,
a decider of who lives and who dies.
Halfway through the annual Purge, Carmelo’s
revolutionary group taps into the video feed
of the countdown to deliver a message to the
people about the NFFA.
His video contains a lot of distortion and
visual glitches which seems to be purely for
aesthetic purposes.
One of the glitches shows New Founding Father
Donald Talbot, and if we pause right as it
happens, the word EVIL is written across his
forehead in the same spot Godhead has written
the word God.
Other subliminal messages in this presentation
include a message reading: Frick the Purge
and a protest sign that says Where Corruption
Begins.
WCB may stand for Workers Compensation Board,
the state agency that provides benefits to
those that get injured during work.
We never hear anything more about this, but
based on what we do know, it’s not hard
to come to the conclusion that the NFFA is
using the Purge to take out people that were
injured on the job so that they don’t have
to pay them.
This would be yet another example of The Purge
disproportionately affecting the working class.
Speaking of which...
LIZ: “You know, we don’t have a lot of time
before commencement, Shane.”
SHANE: “We’ll be fine.
I promise.”
He would not be fine.
The last character we meet is Leo Barnes.
These articles on his wall tell us he’s
the new Jeff Denlon and if you look closely,
you’ll notice the drunk driver who hit his
son was let off the hook just two weeks ago,
around the same time that Leo would have disabled
the man’s security system.
“Two weeks ago I came here and disabled
his back barricade, that’s what we’re
doing here.”
By the way, we spend most of the movie wondering
how Barnes got all his awesome combat skills.
When he drives out of the garage, it looks
like he’s got a cop car with extra metal
armor covering the body.
Then when he comes face to face with this
guy at the end, he says they looked up his
info, and he refers to him “sergeant”.
So it seems like Barnes learned to kick ***
because he used to be a police sergeant.
When The Purge is about to begin, Shane is
still optimistic.
“Hey hey hey. Don't worry.
We’ll figure something out.
I promise.”
Promise.
I do not think he knows what that word means.
Speaking of which, when Eva and her daughter
Cali have their apartment invaded by the sweaty
guy from their building, he seems a little
confused on the name of his favorite government
tyrants, calling them the New Found Fathers.
“It’s my right!
Granted to me by the New Found Fathers.”
Maybe he was confusing them with a certain
late 90s early 2000s pop-punk act, but I just
had to point this out, because it seems to
have predicted this whole 2020 phenomenon
known as the “Karen meme”, where these
people film someone breaking the rules, and
the person freaks out and claims they have
the right to do whatever it is they’re doing
and usually cites made up information and
makes a huge scene.
“I’m going to get my order, and I have
a right.”
The name Karen is thought to be a reference
to a character from the movie Mean Girls,
but there can also be Mankarens, so this guy
screaming about how killing is “his right”,
and incorrectly citing the name of the group
that gave him that “right” seems be an
almost Simpsonseque prediction of events later
to come.
Hopefully this isn’t one of those cases
of life imitates art, though.
I did find a case of art imitates art, when
the characters make it to Tanya’s house.
The news coverage they have playing on the
TV is the same channel that James Sandin watched
a year prior.
Even though this takes place a year later,
the news scroll at the bottom has the exact
same text as the first movie, about parliament’s
criminal imprisonment measures, and a comedian
copyrighting a catch phrase.
Also, it turns out that Shane getting shot
makes Liz realize how much she cares about
him.
LIZ: “I'm sorry.”
SHANE: “No, l got shot.”
LIZ: “Oh, are you gonna use this excuse
for the rest of our lives?”
SHANE: “Well, at least the rest of the night.”
Well.
I guess this time they were both right...
As the group travels through the financial
district, they come across the remains of
a man who has been purged.
There’s a note left on him that says,
“Here hangs stockbroker David Nuestadter.
Stole our pensions now he’s gone.”
However, David Nuestadter is no stockbroker.
He’s a horror film executive producer.
In fact, he’s one of the most prolific horror
film producers of the last decade -- he’s
responsible for funding all of the biggest
hits made by Universal Studio’s rival studio
Warner Bros.
The spelling of the name is way too specific.
Clearly, Universal Studios or director James
Demonaco feels that Nuestadter stole something
from them, and they’re quite bitter about
it.
I’m not sure what that something is… maybe
there were early talks to make The Conjuring
franchise a Universal / Blumhouse movie before
Neustadter swooped in and secured that $2
billion bag for Warner Bros.
Or maybe Demonaco pitched something to him,
and then one of his future movies was a little
too similar to his idea.
If anyone knows what this beef might be about,
let me know in the comments.
The climax of the movie would involve our
characters being kidnapped by Godhead and
his crew and sold off to be victims in this
life-and-death stakes laser tag arena, but
there’s something interesting about the
soundtrack in this sequence.
After being kidnapped and sold to rich NFFA
associates who hunt people for sport, the
main group is put on display to be sold off
along with three other victims, and to add
credibility to Carmelo’s theory, all three
of them are dressed in clothes you’d typically
see on a homeless person.
Also, the music being played during this gala
is a classic piano piece by Chopin.
Much like how the series opens with a montage of purging set to a classic piece by Debussy.
After Shane is picked off by one of the bad
guys, speaking of potentially stolen content,
the soundtrack here sounds exactly like a
Green Day song.
🎵 Slow series of notes from string instrument 🎵
🎵 "21 Guns" - Green Day 🎵
(intro)
Oh wow, the lyrics fit too!
And that in itself it funny, because 21 Guns
has a melody from...
Full House?
Roll it.
🎵 "21 Guns" - Green Day 🎵
(solo)
🎵 "Everywhere you look, everywhere you look!" 🎵
So yeah, that’s how The Purge: Anarchy connects
to Full f***ing House
“This is our time now!”
The team that helps Leo and the others escape
is aided by Dante Bishop from the last movie.
They commandeer a vehicle in the parking lot.
At the beginning, Leo was ordering two innocent
people to get out of his car, essentially
leaving them to die in the Purge; but now
he’s ordering two bad people to do the same
-- it’s only been 12 hours, but his experiences
on this night have already started to shape
his morals.
And about 40 minutes later, we see evidence
of his character development again, when he
decides to let his son’s killer go free.
I guess we don’t technically know that he
was ever planning to kill him, I mean maybe
he was just going to give him a stern talking
to, but most likely, he had malicious intentions,
but changed his mind.
After coming out of the house, he’s finally
hunted down by this guy, who’s known as
Big Daddy.
Not that Big Daddy.
Not THAT Big Daddy.
That Big Daddy.
It’s here that Barnes learns that the NFFA
interferes with the Purge, and this may have
been the moment that inspired him to fight
against the NFFA by going into security work
and protecting their political opponents,
as seen in the next movie.
The final sirens sound, and Leo is rushed
to the hospital.
I think we now know that this is maybe the
most unrealistic part of The Purge, since
we’ve now seen how bad things can get when
hospitals all reach capacity.
In the credits, there are a few hidden
cameos from the first movie, like the interface
of a Sandin Security system, the group that
broke into the Sandins’ house, and James
Sandin himself.
At the beginning of this video, I mentioned
how The Purge: Anarchy is a social commentary
about gun violence in the US.
Demonaco himself has talked about how it explores
the idea that if there was no government, then
what would dictate our morality?
We see that some people will try to take the
law into their own hands.
We see those without guns of their own being
the most vulnerable targets, but when given
a weapon, they fight violence with violence,
because if you can’t afford one, you can’t
really protect yourself through other means,
the purgers will find you.
It starts with just the gun lovers, but we
see participation in The Purge grow year over
year as the groups being gunned down start
to retaliate.
And ultimately, allowing this to go on year
after year causes things to devolve into complete
anarchy.
Click the video on the left for more analysis
of The Purge franchise, and if you love horror
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.
If you don’t want to be purged, you should
stay home.
But if you do have to go out there, wear a
mask.